we're told to graph all possible values
for H on the number line and this is a
especially interesting inequality
because we also have an absolute value
here so the way we're going to do it
we're going to solve for we're going to
solve this inequality in terms of the
absolute value of H and from there we
can solve it for H so let's just get the
absolute value of H on one side of the
equation so the easiest way to do this
is to add 19 and 1/2 to both sides of
this equation I often like putting that
as an improper fraction but 1/2 is
pretty easy to deal with so let's add 19
and 1/2 to both sides of this inequality
can I just say equation it's an
inequality not an equation it's an
inequality sign not an equal sign so
plus 19 and 1/2 on the left-hand side
these guys obviously cancel out that was
the whole point and we are left with the
absolute value of H on the left hand
side is less than and then if we have
what 19 and 1/2 essentially minus 12 19
minus 12 is 7 so it's going to be 7 and
1/2 7 and 1/2 so now we have that the
absolute value of H is less than 7 and
our 7 and 1/2 so what does this tell us
this means that the distance another way
to interpret this remember absolute
value is the same thing as distance from
0 so another way to interpret this
statement is that the distance the
distance from from H to 0 it has to be
less than less than 7 and 1/2 so what
values of H are going to have less than
a distance from 7 and 1/2 well it could
be less than 7 and 1/2 and greater than
0 or equal to 0 so let me put it this
way so H could be H could be less than 7
and 1/2 but if it gets too far negative
if it goes to negative 3 we're cool
negative 4 negative 5 negative 6
negative 7 we're still cool
but then at negative 8 all of a sudden
the absolute value isn't going to be
less than this so it also has to be
greater than
negative seven and a half if you give me
any number in this interval its absolute
value is going to be less than seven and
a half because all of these numbers are
less than seven and a half away from
zero let me draw it on the number line
which they want us to do anyway so if
this is the number line right there that
is zero and let me draw some points
let's say that this is seven that is
eight that is negative seven that is
negative eight what numbers are less
than seven and a half away from zero
well you have everything all the way up
to seven and a half is exactly seven and
a half away so that you can't count that
so seven and a half you'll put a circle
around it same thing true for negative
seven and a half the absolute value it's
exactly seven and a half away but we
have to be less than seven and a half
away so neither of those points are
going to be included positive seven and
1/2 or negative seven and a half now
everything in between is less than seven
and a half away from zero so everything
else counts everything else counts
everything outside of it is clearly more
than seven and a half away from zero and
we're done